five people were shot and killed several
more injured at a newspaper in Annapolis
Maryland this afternoon new information
is coming in to Fox some of it confusing
we're sorting it out we also expect an
update from the police in the next few
minutes and we'll take you there live
when that happens but first good evening
welcome to Tucker Carlson tonight there
was an ideological revolution on the
left this week and hardly anybody
noticed it for months you may have
noticed members of the progressive
fringe had been calling for abolishing
ice that's the agency responsible for
enforcing our immigration laws that's
not a mainstream position obviously and
Democratic leaders seemed embarrassed by
it
Nancy Pelosi and Chuck Schumer opposed
the idea so did many others and then
everything changed
two days ago a self-described socialist
called Alexandria Acacio Cortez
unexpectedly won a Democratic primary in
New York Acacio Cortez ran on abolishing
ice suddenly in days getting rid of Isis
something many Democrats say they are
for now midterm elections are
approaching so it's time for the rest of
us to take this idea seriously what
exactly would happen if the left killed
ice well here's some of the facts about
ice ice is responsible for all
immigration enforcement within the
United States last year ice arrested
32,000 958
illegal immigrants with criminal records
almost 5,000 of those were members of
violent gangs without ice all of those
criminals would still be at large within
our borders
last year ice also seized two thousand
three hundred and seventy pounds of
fentanyl
that's the narcotic that is driving the
single deadliest drug crisis in the
history of this country
that's enough fentanyl to kill every
single American citizen by overdose
without ice that fentanyl would still be
in circulation and of course ice is also
the body responsible for deporting
anybody illegally inside the United
States last year ice removed more than
two hundred and twenty-six thousand
people who broke American law ice did
that because ice is the only agency we
have to do it without ice criminal
aliens could stay in this country with
impunity that would include gang members
drug smugglers child molesters convicted
murderers they could not be deported
companies meanwhile could bring in an
unlimited number of illegal workers that
would crash wages for American citizens
even more than it already has would be a
disaster but as the point the campaign
against Isis is a campaign for open
borders and some are honest enough to
admit that during protests against the
administration activists have chanted
this no borders no nations stop the
deportations no borders no nations one
leads to the other always without
borders nations are impossible if we
pass the law tomorrow
allowing strangers to live in your house
would it still be your house no it would
not be it would be everybody's house
soon it would be nobody's house that's
the less plan for America finally they
are saying it out loud